o paulista da geração carro
aos 16 anos eu tinha meu carro meu
próprio carro que dirigia aos 18 anos em
três carros e não sabe o que é viver sem
meu pai era é empresário da área de
agrotóxicos e eu queria estudar na usp
isso daí foi no começo da década de 70 e
foi vetada porque era um antro não
centro de comunistas e aí meu caminho
natural foi pra onde fundação getúlio
vargas administração de empresas junto
com um filho dos empresários que hoje
estão aí dominando esse país afora até
fora daqui e é a meu pai tinha muito
medo do comunismo na década de 60 e 70
ele dizia que é a tal pintando planeta
vermelho era um pânico geral nessa época
e e um professor meu lado de getúlio
vargas é falou gente comunismo e
esqueçam a as grandes ameaças vêm das
grandes corporações
elas vão dominar o planeta e é muito
pouco tempo a gente chega lá
nós estamos mais 0 nessa era das grandes
corporações
é dessa desse domínio do planeta né
gente transformou tanto o planeta em tão
pouco tempo que nós estamos numa nova
era
o antropoceno causou 50 anos mudanças
muito dramáticas e é a por conta de um
conhecimento fragmentado que vem dessa
cultura cartesiano de isolar as patas né
procura analisar cada parte é tentado
achando que as partes vão explicar o
todo que a gente vai chegar em algum
lugar mas isso não acontece as o todo é
muito mais do que a soma das suas
palavras ea gente perdeu perdeu a noção
do todo
nossa casa o planeta terra ali né
a vida não pode ser explicada pela pela
análise de toda a gente um fígado é um
coração a gente um é um sistema e com
isso a gente criou crise é da maior
gravidade
gente estou aqui pra falar do cenário
negro mesmo não é brincadeira não a
gente tá aí com uma coisa muito feia
acontecendo ea gente é tem que fazer
diferente um pouquinho né meu professor
tinha razão tamos aí na era das grandes
corporações que é cresceram baseados
numa economia é a qualquer custo é não
importa vamos explorar recursos naturais
a gente está muito maior do que o
planeta hoje a gente está consumindo um
planeta e meio e essa era da
globalização é tá chamando por cidades
globais é uma rede de cidades globais é
a que procuram se inserir nessa nessa
economia a qualquer custo e aceitem é e
implicações bastante grandes na porque a
cidade toda são parecidas né eu acordar
de um sonho que não era mil anos dez
anos atrás mais ou menos quando ia fazer
50 anos e entrei pelas paisagens pelas
cidades de um simplesmente me apaixonei
pelo que eu faço
e aí eu tenho viajado já mais de 50 anos
por cidades do mundo inteiro e elas são
todas parecidas não importa a gente vai
é mais ou menos essa imagem da cidade
globalizada que a gente tem sem uma
cidade que eu tive esse ano mas não
importa né
é a gente vive dentro de caixas a gente
perdeu a conexão com a natureza
a gente está focado no consumo qualquer
lugar que a gente vai igual eu tive
dificuldade de escolher foto de shopping
center no mundo inteiro igual gente
as ruas estão sumindo na o que está
acontecendo é isso tudo igual.na tem aí
pelo mundo inteiro e é uma desconexão
tão grande da natureza é que a gente tem
um sonho sei que não tem nada a ver com
a nossa paisagem está desconectado na
nossa cidade não tem nenhuma conexão com
o contexto dela um clima dela ea gente
está pensando cada vez em arquiteturas
mais espetaculares é a modo de
transporte focados em março
em máquinas na ação que sempre cidades
com máquinas com o consumo de energia
absurdo e é a cortadas entrecortadas por
vias que não olham para a paisagem não
olham para os fluxos de água para os
fluxos de biodiversidade também
eliminando os ecossistemas não olha para
as pessoas não consegue cruzar uma rua
né mora no jardim botânico na travessa
rua no tempo e mais uma pessoa que tem
problema de mobilidade que eu não tenho
é é é um desafio porque isso está indo
para o planeta inteiro também inteiro tá
recortado a gente hoje tem as paisagens
completamente entrecortadas dos nossos
ecossistemas estão sendo varridos do
mapa sem margem porque a organização tem
grande impacto isso porque a gente tá
espraiando as nossas cidades
indefinidamente
hoje já foi falado bastante sobre isso
né e o que a gente vê é um salve-se quem
puder
o ano inteiro seja por é falta de água
que é o caso desse ano não é que a gente
está em seca isso é previsto nas
mudanças climáticas não é uma coisa é a
que não vai acontecer mais em setembro
pode não chover de novo tá essa história
que vamos ter chuva esse tempo pode não
acontecer
a gente está dentro de mudanças
climáticas agora quando chove é um
desastre
é um desafio a gente vive uma cidade de
desastre que a gente fez tudo errado a
gente foi é e mudando mesmo aterrando
canalizando as águas ela só aparece
nessa hora
essas águas que estão submersas que
sumiram da paisagem hoje pr mostrou aí
mais uma citação do pr
o pierre mostrou lhe botafogo é a breve
e não tem mais isso aqui é jardim
botânico era lagoa para a água volta não
tem pra onde não tem como escoar as
cidades nesse contexto globalizado que a
gente tá são fundamentais porque a gente
mora em cidade órbita é da humanidade é
a cidade já foi falado já que mais de
metade da humanidade mora em cidades no
brasil já são mais de 85 por cento de
pessoas na memória necessidades ea maior
parte da cidade desses problemas que a
gente vê a gente se de um novo paradigma
a gente tem que entrar é mimetizando a
paisagem entendendo como essa paisagem
funciona como essas águas circulam como
é que essa biodiversidade faz essa
conexão faz a limpeza tais é temperatura
mais amena para a cidade é a captura é
gases de efeito estufa a sombreia
diminui a necessidade de ar condicionado
enfim tem inúmeros serviços
ecossistêmicos que a biodiversidade
prata onde está nas cidades é a cidades
como um ecossistema que a gente tem que
pensar né
é a gente parte disso a gente não está
desconectado da natureza a gente é
natureza
a gente precisa de cidades que ame a
vida são cidades wilf ligas biofilia
quer dizer é se sentir parte da vida
esse termo foi cunhado pelo ego wilson e
enfim isso é que é uma rede de cidades
bíblicas da qual eu faço parte e
adoraria ver a minha cidade do rio de
janeiro parte daqui a gente vai promover
ano que vem 11 seminário numa
conferência aqui é na boca do rio
e aí eu visitei algumas cidades e da
necessidade eu escolhi 4 eu visitei
algumas não existem muitas estão fazendo
direito eu escolhi 4 frango que é uma
cidade emblemática porque tinha é é uma
usina sendo construída na sua porta
usina nuclear e eles foram virarão na
economia via de uma década de 70 e
devolvida é é a cidade das pessoas com
verdes crianças estão livres de
prioridade para o transporte de massa
até os parquinhos mimetiza com a
paisagem é transporte limpo é paris é a
outra cidade que escolhi porque é um
país que tem uma relação emocional eu
vou para lá há quarenta e tantos anos e
para isto é que sempre foi legal agora
está espetacular porque eles estão com
biodiversidade em todos os lugares têm
uma cultura de biodiversidade
acontecendo lá estão tirando o carro
enfim é é assim visível isso acontecer e
isso traz visita é uma nova economia
traz turistas traz gera novos empregos
mas aqui é um jardim de crianças é no
meio de paris nem todas as pás nova york
eu fiquei 20 anos sem ir porque não
suportava
portas cidade barulhenta e enfim eu sou
feliz idade
aí voltei no passado para lá trabalho
etapa pesquisando nova york ficou
espetacular
tirando os casos envolvendo pessoas
estão em frente há meses aqui no brasil
o impacto mais imediato nenhuma livraria
nem da cidade na 60 escolhe o livro você
quer ler se e lê é a ciclovia pela
cidade inteira na ônibus é uma duas
fazendas é comerciais em lages
isso aí tá acontecendo orgânica vendendo
para restaurante para as pessoas e pode
comprar lá tem dia do mercado na é aí eu
acho que a cidade mais emblemática que
eu posso contar pra vocês é a cidade de
ceo que fica na coréia do sul é toda vez
que a pesquisa aparecia o tal do córrego
cheonggyecheon que é uma renaturalização
que foi feita lá cheguei lá a
oportunidade que eu tive em 2011 eu fui
prazer
desembarquei eu encontrei muito mais
nerd tiveram as mesmas oportunidades que
o rio está tendo teve primeiro ou o
parque olímpico nas olimpíadas de 88
fizeram parte é ecológica ou milhões e
setecentos metros quadrados chamou ééé é
restaurar recuperar uma área degradada
reconhece que é assim nem fora da cidade
- o meia hora de metrô que é o método
mais moderno que eu conheci na minha
vida 11 conhece o outro
aliás eu não tenho carro mas está livre
de carros anos atrás
é isso aqui é o parque de ser urgente é
a arte tem seis estádios têm museu é o
máximo e sensacional
aí na copa do mundo de 2002 teve a
segunda oportunidade 15 parques não foi
esses dois aqui obstar a que eu voltei e
sic e sic são dois modos de lixo ou
gramacho é genial as pessoas estão lá há
ali é um monte de lixo ali é é a que o
estádio na série está foi a final da
copa do mundo aí mas é muito mais disso
eles fizeram alagados construídos gente
eles construíram áreas para tratar as
águas desse rio
tratando inteira tem um plano verde pra
recuperar é ser um que é uma cidade que
também cresceu a qualquer curso e de
outras pessoas isso aqui não existia
sequer na área degradada na beira do rio
há aqui e saiu alagado construído mesmo
as pessoas fazem piquenique é genial
e aí eu vou chegar no córrego era isso
que estava entubado aqui embaixo etsi
viaduto por cima na cidade é onde a
cidade se originou e ii
eles foram limpando tudo é como se a
gente sair da cinelândia que o rio de
janeiro está sai da cinelândia sob o
branco entra na presidente vargas e
deságua na baía de guanabara é essa
extensão de trabalho que eles fizeram se
eu falar pra vocês o curso vocês vão
achar que estou mentindo luiza que a
maquete que está lá no museu é 22 fontes
na reconectando costurando tecido urbano
públicos e pobres de novo se passa de um
lado pro outro nem sabe que está
mantiveram a cultura é despoluir enfim é
um projeto é interessantíssimo que a
praça central eu vou passar rapidinho
que de sendo que o tempo está correndo
hoje é isso biodiversidade dentro tx é
as pessoas estão dentro d'água bebendo a
água é sensacional e essa foto que eu
cheguei à hora que estava em cima da
ponte eu vinha descendo procurando achei
que era mais embaixo olhei era final do
dia falei caramba é muito melhor do que
nos livros é muito melhor do que nem no
na internet e é genial quem já teve lá
isso é um trabalho que acomoda água de
200 anos de chuva e frio com a cidade em
cinco graus está preparado para as
mudanças climáticas
é quando tem enchente e não dá em baixo
não chega no lugar onde as pessoas estão
enfim tem muita coisa que tiver eheheheh
tem aí eu deixo aqui
aí eu sou mais estranha no ninho porque
a gente está divida em outro planeta na
vanguarda no brasil a gente não tem
mudanças
ficai cidade linda né pra que a gente
vai se preocupar com a mudança climática
falta d'água é poluição pode paisagem
paisagem do património nada na da
humanidade gente unesco e aí a gente
continua fazendo a mesma coisa que ele
fez lá pra barra da tijuca na baixada de
jacarepaguá
vamos atacar do mesmo jeito aterro que
analisa rio elimina que o sistema pra
que é bobagem mudança climática elevação
do nível do mar
bobagem né é a dica reserva ecológica a
quem precisa na bota alto de buffy
melhor
mas aí já em seia ó esse mapa que foi
produzido por um órgão público que eu
acho que tem gente aqui inclusive
presidente na frutal aipim 2008
quem as recomendações
ninguém está olhando pra nenhuma nada
tão passando a régua em cima na nenhuma
não porque eu também não posso falar
isso quando o estudo está sendo feito né
mas até onde eu pesquisei é isso aí nós
nessa parte desse grupo que fez a
proposta para o corredor verde olímpico
nesta baixada
a gente fez baseado nesse mapeamento uma
proposta para fazer uma intervenção que
contemplasse isso as mudanças climáticas
e conectar suas águas ajudar a despoluir
é novidade limpa enfim um monte de coisa
super legal e aqui na escala das pessoas
a ajuda de gente não serve roche
essa coisa de vidro é espelhado estado
histórias londres quem detém um jaguar
ano para ano passado né
e aqui a gente com esse clima inclemente
fazendo isso a gente diz idade escolar
como florestas e edifícios como árvores
ea gente precisa de lugares assim que
respeitem a natureza na que convivam com
ela a gente é de harmonia com a natureza
aqui é um outro grupo sensacional que
tem gente pra caramba aqui que a gente
se reuniu em 2009 fundou uma uma
organização ea gente fez uma proposta
pra é uma intervenção no estuário do rio
dos macacos ele tinha esperança que sair
para ver mais vídeos
isso aí eu trouxe a última imagem porque
esse canal é que podia ser em qualquer
lugar
nessa semana de gre nal gasolina traz o
choque mas já está cheio pela cidade ea
gente fez a mama renaturalização nesse
canal tv a proposta vem desde a barba
lado da nascente na rede vencendo e aí a
gente termina e tira carro que enfim a
nossa proposta realmente era muito legal
né e até à praia na verdade
a gente faz uma entrada da lagoa e é
isso é hoje eu faço o que eu mais gosto
eu nunca pude imaginar que é ser
professora na minha vida porque eu
achava que era terrível se professor
jamais falar em público e não levanta
nenhuma sala de aula gv e ficava muda
eu não te falar na quadra que fica agora
vem falar e aí é que eu adoro da aula só
porque é porque me sinto uma árvore
eu lanço sementes na europa atingindo a
cabeça das pessoas quanto eu aprendo
legal quando a gente faz o que gosta é a
melhor coisa do mundo
quando vocês adições dos outros e entra
em seu signo honesta consigo mesmo e não
tem preço é bom demais e eu quero deixar
um mundo melhor
na aqui estão minhas pintinhas não só
para elas mas para as próximas gerações
e as outras e as outras brigadas